what was your relationship like with
Andre Andre was good good he lived in
lrb North Carolina I live in North
Carolina right now but I used to live
there a lot more and he would always
have a little party once in a while and
he had this house that was made for him
Gaius house his evil was probably the
size of most people's home all the
doorways were 15 you know feet high and
he had a like a double king put together
and chairs were made for him and if
Audrey liked you you were fine if he
didn't like you it was a pretty rough
night they said he didn't like John
Studd hated John John Studd was
terrified he was it was terrified of him
once a while I have John at my car we'd
be traveling he he talked about it I
almost get tears in his eyes I don't
know why because you're trying to slam
him you know he doesn't want to be
slammed so they're like good you know it
just it's a business we're just we're
just all working together you know
doesn't want to but he but he would try
to I think you did he would try to put a
hurtin on the money oil yeah and Audrey
if he was in a good mood you were fine
right you know one night I got him and
he'd been on the road come back from
Japan little town and New Jersey people
were coming out of the Woodworks and I
come to the to the arena and Andres not
there yet his planes late finally one of
the guys said just go out he's on his
way
go rile up the people when they when
he's here I'll send the referee okay so
here comes the referee it looks at me
you're in forget diamonds on the beams
Devon do you stop the plane and and he's
in a great mood you know so here he
comes and I get him in the ring and he
used to kind of play around with me and
so I got I'm gonna front facelock
and he's just as hairy like a lion you
know and I hit him in his front facelock
and of course we we put some pressure on
a pretty heavy a lot of times
just to get around with some of the guys
we like and so I tell the referee lift
his tellin ask him he wants to give up
you know give up to the Sarge
so the referee picks up his paw and he
drops it down and and there's no
movement so listen up again I said ask
him if he wants to give up and down
there was a paw in and all of a sudden I
looked at the referee and I said to
myself something's not right and all of
a sudden was Andre Fowles so tired from
a trip that he choked him out dawn get
up now I'm trying to wake him up we've
only been in the match five so I'm
hitting wrong back it finally reached up
and all he's mad at me so he starts to
walk him up oh yeah
like a grizzly bear and I started
running around the rain he's coming
after me I jumped over the top rope he
coming over the top run around finally I
had it back to the dressing he's left I
ran around the the locker room the
lockers and he's chasing me around and I
said what do I do
irony stolen was the road agent back
then he's I don't know kid he's got a
cigar the little kid so I saw the kids
private Daniels who used to write drive
my camouflage limo I said get the car
ready
it said of the cars he gets the car
ready so I run around run around on do
they still follow me I see the exit door
I hit the exit door and the perfect
timing there's my camouflage limo the
back doors open I fly into it and off we
go and I look back and there's our on
tree that's so funny
next day he got got all the bay but he
did get all the fun fun stories so he
was quite a drink right here to go
drinking with him oh yeah yeah he put
him down yeah they said he was [ __ ]
really pound pound beers I mean his hand
yeah bigger than a beer camera yeah yeah
he would he didn't creak out of a class
he just drank the bottle of wine right
let me I'm gonna have a cup of wine that
means two bottles yeah yeah
but he was a great guy good man one more
Jim and Sam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the SiriusXM a